Supongamos que dos personas
van caminado por la calle
y se chocan entre sí.
Simplemente será un sacudón
y seguirán camino.
A veces pasa lo mismo con las moléculas.
Simplemente rebotan entre sí, y eso es todo.
Pero, ¿qué pasaría si dos personas chocaran
y durante la colisión
una persona perdiera un brazo
y éste quedara en la cara
de la otra persona?
Suena muy raro,
pero es similar a una
de las muchas formas
en que pueden reaccionar las moléculas.
Dos moléculas pueden unirse en una sola.
Una puede separarse en dos.
Las moléculas pueden intercambiar partes.
Todos estos cambios son reacciones químicas,
y podemos verlas ocurrir a nuestro alrededor.
Por ejemplo, en la explosión
de fuegos artificiales
o en el hierro oxidado
o cuando la leche se echa a perder
o cuando las personas nacen
envejecen,
mueren,
y luego se descomponen.
Pero las reacciones químicas
¡no ocurren sí o sí!
Todo tiene que cuadrar.
Primero, las moléculas tienen que chocar
en la orientación correcta.
Segundo, tienen que chocar
lo suficientemente fuerte;
es decir, con suficiente energía.
Probablemente piensas
que la reacción ocurre solo
en una dirección y eso es todo.
A veces es así.
Por ejemplo, las cosas
no pueden "desquemarse"
o "inexplotar".
Pero la mayoría de las reacciones
pueden ocurrir en ambas direcciones
hacia adelante y hacia atrás.
No hay razón por la que
el tipo del brazo en la cara
no pueda chocar con la chica sin brazo,
y volverle a colocar el brazo en su sitio.
Alejémonos un poco.
Digamos que hay
mil personas en la calle,
y todas empiezan con sus extremidades
adheridas normalmente.
Al principio, toda colisión
es una posibilidad
de que la Persona A le transfiera el brazo
a la cara de la Persona B.
Así, al principio,
cada vez más personas terminan
con brazos en la cara o con brazos perdidos.
Pero conforme aumenta la cantidad
de personas con brazos en la cara
y brazos perdidos
las colisiones entre esas personas
se hacen más probables.
Y cuando chocan entre sí,
adivinen qué.
Se reproducen los casos
de extremidades normales.
La cantidad de transferencias
de extremidades por segundo
empezará alta y luego caerá.
Y la cantidad de recuperaciones
de extremidades por segundo
empezará en cero y luego aumentará.
Finalmente se encontrarán,
y serán lo mismo.
Y cuando eso suceda,
la cantidad de personas
en cada estado dejará de cambiar,
aunque las personas sigan
chocando unas contra otras
e intercambien extremidades.
¿Cuántas personas piensan
que habrá en cada estado?
Mitad y mitad, ¿no?
No, bueno, quizá.
Depende.
Podría ser 50/50,
pero podría ser 60/40,
15/85
u otra proporción.
Los químicos tienen que ensuciarse los guantes...
--ah, bueno, estamos en el laboratorio,
a no ensuciarse tanto--
para averiguar la distribución real
de moléculas.
Si bien cada transferencia
de extremidades
es bastante dramática para
las personas involucradas,
si nos alejamos,
vemos cifras de población que no cambian.
Llamamos a este nirvana: equilibrio,
y no solo ocurre con las reacciones químicas.
Cosas como las reservas genéticas
y el tránsito de la carretera
muestran el mismo patrón.
Se ve bastante estático a 9000 metros,
pero ocurren muchas cosas locas
en la superficie,
solo hay que acercarse para verlas.